the DARPA lager program aims to advance
learning algorithms in off-road robotics
the main challenge in off-road robotics
is the highly changing and unstructured
environment learning algorithms can
adapt to changes in lighting conditions
and obstacles appearance where
conventional algorithms often fail the
logger vehicle provided by Enric comes
with four cameras allowing passive
stereo vision a GPS receiver used to
reach a GPS goal and four onboard
computers stereo vision is typically
reliable only up to about 12 meters
increasing this range with passive
vision remains highly challenging a
short-sighted robot makes poor decisions
and will get stuck in cul-de-sacs net
scale technologies and new york
university have focused their effort on
developing machine learning techniques
for long-range vision along with a
robust and collision free software
navigation platform this long-range
vision system increases the vision range
of the robot to 50 or even a hundred
meters or more the robot first finds the
horizon using a ground plane extracted
from stereo points it then builds a
series of normalized image bands at
different distances so that it can train
on and classify objects of all sizes the
convolutional neural network is trained
both offline and online using a
short-range stereo labels such as
traversable and obstacle to learn the
appearance of natural obstacles which
are then classified in the long range
patches of the image this technique has
been dubbed near to far learning
convolutional neural networks are
particularly well suited for extracting
features from images while providing
scale and translation invariance two
layers of convolution separated by a max
pooling layer produce a hundred
dimensional feature vector for each
point in the image bands the feature
extractor is trained offline using logs
captured during the full duration of the
program the online logistic regression
classifier identifies the features as
traversable and
and constantly updates the
classification of distant patches based
on the labels produced by the stereo in
the near range the labels are organized
in a hyperbolic polar map which is an
efficient pseudo image space
representation whose resolution drops
off with distance thus fitting the
inherent range uncertainty of long-range
vision and providing an appropriate
space for mapping and planning on the
left is the hyperbolic polar cost map
and on the right the RGB information as
the long-range vision requires heavy
processing a multi-layer perception and
planning architecture guarantees a high
reactivity while the robot thinks about
long-term decisions on the right an
independent fast and short-range vision
system detects obstacles in real-time
and avoids all collisions another key
module is the rotational visual odometry
which corrects the unreliable
positioning system using vision at very
low computational cost compared to
traditional methods in this aerial view
the non visually corrected poses in
black and green use only odometers IMU
and GPS but both are incorrect a
traditional full visual odometry system
outputs the slightly incorrect red curve
which is of comparable accuracy to our
hybrid visual odometry in blue but is
significantly slower another key
component that makes our robot smoothly
avoid all obstacles is the cheap and
efficient trajectory recording module
our robot models its dynamics by
recording a set of possible trajectories
into a bank which you see here when
running the robot query is the
trajectory bank to know what it can do
based on its current wheel speeds and
selects the best trajectory given the
current cost map after a few hours of
human or self supervised driving the
robot knows what trajectories are
possible and navigate smoothly around
obstacles it can even learn new
trajectories and improve by itself this
very simple technique requires minimal
engineering
effort but is capable of modeling
complicated trajectories it completely
bypasses the need for traditional
complex parameter identification and
tuning to conclude the net scale nyu
system has proven its long range
capabilities in various government tests
and numerous non official tests thanks
to machine learning and a solid
efficient software navigation platform